joining us now one of the finest
safeties in the national football league
i was going to say young safeties but
young old or in between jamal adams is
among the very best and he is back on
the program jamal how are you pal
i'm good man how you doing
i'm doing good i saw doing the reset
because i do research you know we got we
got to be ready for these i saw that you
were number 37 on the top 100 list of
nfl players for 2019. how high is that
going to go for 2020
uh man you know each and every year
we're trying to you know uh get better
so you know hopefully it goes up uh
that's definitely my plan but um at the
end of the day i'm all about the team
and our success man
you've had a lot of individual success
though and this is only your third nfl
season what's the biggest reason why
you've been so good so quickly
it's just putting time and effort into
it a lot of sacrifice man a lot of
sacrifices as far as you know family
time
as far as you know
doing doing things outside of you know
football outside of the facility
just just having that focus man i think
that's that's what you know
helped me you know get get over the top
my second year um as far as you know you
know reaching the pro bowl um getting
the mvp of the pro bowl and um things
like that so so it's always good to you
know uh put out goals for yourself and
and just going to reach them doing
whatever it takes to reach them
where do you keep the trophy that you
get for being mvp of the pro bowl
it was crazy man they didn't even give
us the trophy man
i thought they had a trophy
nah we didn't even get a trophy
me and pat just got a car
well that's even better it's a trophy
yeah so i guess that's the trophy man we
got the car in the parking lot man
yeah well that's good congratulations on
that now look week one hey you know
sometimes it works out sometimes it
doesn't how long does it take you to get
over a game like the one that unfolded
on sunday
yeah it takes 24 hours for me man maybe
maybe 27 hours now i can put it like
that but man like you said you hit it um
and you answered it um in the right way
man it happened it didn't roll our way
like we wanted but it's just one game um
and it's not the end of the world we
have another opportunity
monday night on prime time and we're
looking forward to that man
i saw that you said yesterday the energy
died for the jets on sunday what was it
specifically that caused that to happen
you know i i can't answer that but i i
think you know as a defense
you know i just speak for defense i
never speak on the offense because um
they have a tough task at hand but we
gotta we gotta finish uh you know
opponents when we have them down and um
we just gotta you know continue to you
know do what we did in the first half
and you know i i definitely challenged
the group um to to continue to do that
um to continue to get better off of that
um and we'll be fine man i'm i'm i
definitely have no doubt in my mind that
we'll we'll bounce back from it
jamal what do you carry away from what
happened sunday that will help you as a
team moving forward
just finishing man we got to finish that
that's what i take from it um when you
have them down uh opponent down you
definitely gotta continue to go at them
and uh you know make sure make sure that
the game is over with
cj mosley was a force of nature in his
first game with the team suffered a
groin injury and exited what impact did
that have on the defense
yeah it's tough losing you know a guy
like cj
he was playing he was playing lights out
um obviously everybody knows he's a
beast and um but it's next man up
mentality you know everybody gets
coached the same
um everybody gets the same nuggets the
same notes
on game days and and at practice
so this next man up philosophy um you
know i know she will be fine he'll be
back sooner or later um and we're
looking forward to having him back out
there
give me the best thing you guys did as a
defense that you can point to and say we
can carry this over and this is going to
help us be as good as we can be
turnovers
we have four plus turnovers really
should have had about six
um but we had we had a lot of turnovers
man anytime you can do that as a defense
you put your
team in a better predicament to win ball
games
you know one thing that didn't go right
for the jets on sunday a couple of
missed kicks do you say anything to the
kicker when he misses an extra point or
a field goal
no it's not my place man i know it's a
tough job at hand
and
i don't know what's going through
kicker's minds
but that's that's not my job that's not
my you know my place all i can do as a
teammate is just to lift him up and
continue to you know
help him stay positive
one new teammate you have this year
running back le'veon bell what's been
your impression of him so far
everything that you know i thought about
le'veon before he came here um
he's the whole package
but now not only is he a football player
he's a hell of a team a hell of a person
off the field and
i don't think many people give him the
recognition
as far as that
sam darnold entering year two you've
gotten to watch him very carefully
during his nfl career what's different
about him this year versus last year
yeah his poison and his confidence i
think that's the main thing that sticks
out for me and i know he's going to
continue to get better each and every
week and
i know he's uh he's looking forward to
each and every match-up
to go out there and compete because he's
definitely one of those competitors
does it get feisty during practice greg
williams is a guy that likes to stir the
pot a little bit has that sparked more
of a rivalry in-house between defense
and offense
yeah it's definitely fun to go out there
each and every each and every day really
man and go out there and compete that's
all we do that's what makes us better as
a group and
like i said man anytime you can go out
there and compete
on both sides of the ball that's what
makes the team um you know better in the
long run so
anytime we're out there it's definitely
a show
what's the craziest thing you've heard
greg williams say
man
nothing nothing crazy man
that's gonna stir up that's gonna stir
up a lot of stuff man so i'm gonna just
stay away from that
uh
the the browns are coming up on monday
night you mentioned that prime time game
you faced the browns last year you saw
baker mayfield what did you learn from
him last year that will help you this
year
yeah baker is a is a hell of a
competitor man i i love that about him
um he's a guy that's going to get his
get his troops ready to play and um he's
going he's going to compete he's going
to bring energy so um all game long it's
going to be fun it's going to be a lot
of trash talking already you know uh so
i can tell you that you know we're just
looking forward to the challenge
have you seen this thing about odell
beckham jr and the watch that he wore on
sunday 350 000 watch
yeah i definitely did apparently he's
gonna wear that monday night now if if
it were me out there forget about trying
to tackle the guy i'm taking that watch
and i'm sticking it down the back of my
pants and i don't know where it is
you're gonna try to do that
hey man i'm not worried about his watch
man we just gotta get him down for the
best of our ability
[Laughter]
um the uh the cleveland browns have all
that hype coming into the seas and i got
the impression that titans had maybe
heard a little bit enough of it going
into week one are you sick of hearing
about how good the browns are supposed
to be
man again i'm not i'm not
our focus is is on the browns but our
focus is you know in the locker room in
the in the building man we're just
focused on the jets
focus on how we can get better um but
that is definitely um opponent that that
that we have up next and uh they're well
coached uh have a lot of superstar
talent on that side and uh we're just
looking forward to you know competing
with those guys
you got your first look at josh allen in
his second year he was another guy taken
in the top ten like sam darnold and
baker mayfield did you see anything
significantly different about him this
year than what you saw last year
no not at all really man
he's a competitor as well and
it was fun competing to get some
jamal adams is here today on behalf of
lunatics the only ticket site that lets
fans reserve playoff tickets for any
team in any game all year long and
they're giving out golden tickets to
fans across the country whoever gets the
golden ticket will receive two tickets
to every home playoff game in their city
in any sport including the super bowl
through the end of next year my goodness
where do people learn more about this
lunatics program jamal
man go to lunatics.com man you hit it
man it's the best the best ticket site
out there um man if you want a great
experience um as a sports fan um to
witness your team i advise you to go on
lunatics.com it's very simple man
so if somebody wins this and they get
the golden ticket they live in new york
are they going to be going to new jersey
to see a jets game uh in january
hey man
we'll worry about that when the time
comes
[Laughter]
all right jamal hey buddy
congratulations on all your success we
look forward to seeing what you guys do
on monday night and for the rest of the
2019 season again best wishes
congratulations and we hope to talk to
you again soon
thank you buddy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports